DYLAN THOMAS: Hello and welcome
to "What in the
World," a show where
GeoGoogler's help you get the
most of your Enterprise
Maps products,
with tips and advice.
My name is Dylan Thomas.
I'm a community manager
on the Maps team.
And joining me today
is Dave McClusky.
Dave is a solutions engineer,
helping Enterprise customers
architect and validate
their solutions.
Hi Dave.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Hi Dylan.
DYLAN THOMAS: And so Dave,
today, is going to be talking
specifically about the Places
API, which is a set of APIs
that are part of the Enterprise
Maps solution set
product suite.
So Dave, take it away.
Let's see what we've
got today.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Sure, thanks.
So yeah, Dylan mentioned today
I'm going to talk to you about
the Places API, which is a very
powerful API, that allows
you to integrate Google's
database of over 100 million
points of interest, into your
web or mobile application.
If you're not familiar with the
Places API, it provides a
search capability to look for
local points of interest, like
restaurants, or any sorts of
landmarks, bring them into
your application.
You can do a variety of searches
based off keywords,
or text queries.
And you can bring in some
detailed information about
these points of interest-- like
reviews, opening hours,
costs, business photos, and
including Zagat reviews.
So since we acquired Zagat
back in 2011, we've been
working to incorporate those
premium editorial reviews,
into the Places API service.
And allow you to leverage
those reviews in the
application.
Another really cool feature
about the Places API is the
Autocomplete service.
So this provides that type
ahead, address autocomplete
functionality that a lot of
users have come to expect from
a Google Maps service.
Being able to type in an address
and select from a drop
down list suggested addresses.
So I'll give you a quick demo,
just to show you here what I'm
talking about.
OK, so this demonstration uses
the Places API to bring in
some local content into
a web application.
So what you see here at the top
is the use of the Google
Maps API to show a Google Map
as well a street view image
here on the right.
At the top the Google Map,
there's a search box.
And this is using the
Autocomplete API.
So you can use this Autocomplete
API not only to
autocomplete an address query,
but also categories, or
restaurant names.
So in this example, I'm
searching for restaurants.
And I brought those results of
the restaurant search here
onto my map.
I'm displaying it as markers
on the map, and if you look
below, I'm also displaying
the text-based results.
So all this information that
you're seeing here is coming
straight out of the
Places API.
On the left, I'm showing
the Zagat score.
And in the center here,
I'm showing the
Zagat editorial review.
And on the right, I'm showing
the business photo, that's
coming from the Places
API service.
There's a lot more information
that's available in the Places
API that I'm not showing.
You can bring in price,
for example.
Is this an expensive restaurant,
an inexpensive
restaurant?
You can bring in information
like operating hours.
Are they open now, or not?
You can also bring in Google+
reviews, as well.
So in addition to the Zagat
reviews, there are those
Google+ reviews, as well, that
you can incorporate.
DYLAN THOMAS: So this is
obviously pretty good for
entertainment and hospitality
industry.
It looks like you sort of focus
this on restaurants in
your Autocomplete, as well.
Is that something--
I think that's something
you can control, right?
Whether you're going to focus
the Autocomplete results on
addresses, or a certain
kind of place.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Yeah, and it
turns out, in our Places API
database, like I mentioned,
there are
over 100 million places.
We have something like 60
different categories you can
choose from.
So I'm showing restaurants, but
you can search airports,
banks, ATMs.
There's tons of different
categories.
Hospitals, it goes on
and on, really.
So it's quite a bit
of information.
And it is great, as you
mentioned-- hospitality sites,
travel sites, hotel sites, any
sort of site that wants to
enable location-aware content.
This is very, very valuable,
especially for mobile
applications, as well.
DYLAN THOMAS: OK, and then one
other thing I wanted to ask
there is, can you make it
sort of really obvious.
Which parts of what you're
showing here are actually the
Maps API, the JavaScript library
there, and which parts
are the Places API is
adding to the mix?
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Sure, so here
at the top, I'm showing a
Google Map.
Here on the left, and a street
view image on the right,
that's all coming from the
Google Maps JavaScript API.
And it's pretty cool being
able to tie these
two services together.
But all this location
information that I'm showing,
this point of interest
information about the
restaurants, these addresses of
the restaurants, that's all
coming from the Places
service.
In this case, I'm using the
Places API web service.
There is a JavaScript version
and a web service version.
And I'll get into that in a
little bit more detail about
when you want to use which.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it, thanks.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: So as I just
mentioned, there is a
JavaScript version, as well as
a web service version of the
Places API.
I say typically, you want
to use the JavaScript
version, if you can.
It's very easy to use.
It's well integrated with
the Google Maps API.
When you want to use the web
service version, is typically
when you need to call
it from a server.
When you don't have a client
application, for example.
If you need to make a lot bulk
or batch requests, the web
services are preferred.
One thing to note, however, is
those Zagat reviews are only
currently available in
the web service.
So if you want to incorporate
those premium editorial
reviews, you do need to be using
the web service to get
that information.
DYLAN THOMAS: And I think what
you're showing here, also, is
one of the big topics that comes
up with our customers,
as they move from the free
version of the API, with its
capabilities, to the Enterprise,
or the business
version of the API, is real
quota consideration, and what
changes there.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Right, so when
you're using the free version
of the API, you start off with
1,000 free queries a day.
If you verify your identity and
put in a credit card, that
gets upped to 100,000
queries a day.
But you don't get the Zagat
reviews, that's only in the
Enterprise license.
And you don't get support or
service level agreement.
Your need your Enterprise
license for that.
And of course with Enterprise
license, that can be sized for
whatever amount of quota that
you need, the number of
queries that you need per day,
we can size you for that.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it,
so it's sort of
the queries per second.
Then it's also the maximum, the
total daily quota, are the
two things that you're looking
at when you're validating this
enterprise solution, versus
a free version, right?
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Exactly, and I
can explain a little bit more
about how we count quota
for the Places.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh
perfect, great.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: So essentially
every sort of request to
Places API counts as a query,
as a request, against that
100,000 per day quota limit
that you have, or whatever
you've negotiate as part of
your business license.
There are a few exceptions.
So for example, if you're doing
a normal search, that
counts as a request.
But we also have something
called a radar search, and a
text search.
These are a little bit different
types of searches
you can do.
A radar search brings in
a lot more results.
And a text search allows you
to perform more of a Google
natural language
type of query.
Like pizza in New York, a
string type of query.
And those count as five
or 10 queries each.
So It's a little bit more
than a standard search.
The other sorts of operations
count as one query each, so
such as, bringing in
a Zagat review.
That's an extra request.
Or bringing in a business
photo, for example.
That's an extra request.
So you need to start looking
at your implementation to
really assess how many queries
you're going to be using.
So it does vary heavily
by your implentation.
And you can design your
applications to use a lot or
to use a little.
The Autocomplete API is
something else we get asked a
lot about, as well.
And that also counts as a query,
every time you call
that Autocomplete API service.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it, and I've
noticed that you've got some
things in red.
These are clearly differences
between the web service and
the JavaScript API.
So that's if you're doing some
sort of crowd action.
If you're working with Places to
add and remove them, which
is a capability of the API, it
looks like that is something
you only want to be
doing, or can do
through the web service.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Yeah,
that's true.
So for the most part, the
functionality is duplicated
across both services.
There are a few differences.
So some of the actions, these
are called actions, to add a
place, delete a place, those are
only available through the
web service version.
As well as the Zagat reviews,
those are only available
through the web service
version.
DYLAN THOMAS: One other thing
I was just thinking of here,
is that we showed an example
using the Maps API, and the
Street View API, but you
can also use the Places
Autocomplete, independent of
a map entirely, right?
You can just use that to get
really good address input to
your application.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: That's right.
So you can use the
whole Places API
without a Google Map.
We don't require that you show
the results on a Google Map.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it.
I think we have some--
maybe some idea about what
you could do with that.
Which other kind of map you
might want to put that on
downstream.
But yeah, you don't have to
have a map while you're
finding the address, I think.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: So you can't
Places data on a non-Google
Map, but it doesn't have
to be on a map.
DYLAN THOMAS: Because that
would just not be cool.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE MCCLUSKY: So maybe I can
walk you through an example.
Because that quota does get a
little complicated sometimes.
I can show you that example
of the demo I just showed.
And show you how many counts, or
queries against that quota
that would take up.
DYLAN THOMAS: Excellent.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: So in
the example that I
showed, typing in--
so taking a look at the
screen shot here--
I'm starting to type in a
query, so for the word
restaurant.
Say I type in the first
four letters--
R-E-S-T. And if I call the
Autocomplete API each time,
that would be four queries
right there.
When I perform a text search,
that could be 10 queries.
And then say if I show six
results, and for each one of
those results, I show
a Zagat review.
And for each one of those
results, I show a business
photo, that would be six
more requests each.
So just showing this page for
the screenshot here that that
I'm showing, would be about 26
requests to the Places API.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh, this
is really helpful.
So presumably this is the kind
of thing that you talk with
customers about, when they're
going through an
implementation, is to just take
a really close look at
how they are using it.
And what the impact is on their
quota, and also their
performance on the page.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: That's right.
How you design this application
is going to affect
how many requests
you're making.
For example, if you wanted to
have the user click before you
show a Zagat review, you could
optimize the number of queries
you make by waiting for that
user action before you make
the request.
As opposed to showing them all
automatically, like I am here.
DYLAN THOMAS: Oh, that's a good
watch point, actually.
I didn't think of that one.
That's a really good tip.
That's why we're
talking to you.
So let me just ask you one
other question then.
It seems like some of the
Enterprise angle of this is
quite heavily geared towards
the management of quota and
keeping a watch on things.
Do you have any suggestions
about how people can plan for
the initial launch of their
site, or track for things that
you've seen, like the quota
being blown out, due to a very
successful website launch,
for example?
What are the kinds of things you
tell customers they should
do, to get ready for
that kind of thing?
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Sure, so I mean
the most important thing you
can do is upfront planning.
Understanding how we count
quota, and planning your
application accordingly,
to make
efficient use of your quota.
The next thing is we offer a
variety of usage reports.
So within the API console, you
can track your usage against
these services to see how much
usage you're getting.
And track that over time.
And then as you're approaching,
running out of
quota, we do send emails
alerting you at various
points, that you're reaching
the end of the quota.
DYLAN THOMAS: Got it, so you can
sort of do the proactive
thing yourself.
But then if you start getting
emails from Google letting you
know you're getting close, then
you probably want to take
a close look at that, and
potentially get in touch with
Google, right?
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Right, and
definitely monitoring those
usage reports over time to
make sure there are no
surprises is really key.
DYLAN THOMAS: Cool,
great, good tips.
Thanks very much.
So Dave, I think we're pretty
much at time now.
I want to thank you for your
insights and going over the
products, really helpful.
DAVE MCCLUSKY: Thanks, Dylan.
DYLAN THOMAS: And we'll
see you next time on
"What in the World."